[Music]
hi I'm Patti Kim we're taking off for
Egypt and one of the most extraordinary
sites in the world the Pyramids at Giza
just outside Cairo built to honour the
ancient Egyptian rulers these iconic
pyramids attract thousands of people
every day
now the crowds can be a little bit
overwhelming so here are a few tips to
make your trip as hassle-free and is
amazing
as it ought to be for over 4,000 years
the Pyramids at Giza have attracted
visitors with their size grandeur and
mystery many secrets about these
magnificent structures remain built to
its Dan eternity they seem in no hurry
to reveal them to the ancient Egyptians
the pyramids were both tombs and
individual units within a vast temple
network they were holy sites tended by
royal priests built to safeguard the
worldly remains of the Pharaohs from
Thebes and transport them into the
afterlife the largest the Great Pyramid
of Khufu today stands almost 450 feet
tall thousands of workers labored to
build the Pyramid to the pharaoh Khufu
brained about 2,500 BC over 2 million
stone blocks were used each averaging
about two and a half tons despite its
size experts believe it took perhaps
only 20 years to complete the middle
pyramid the tomb of the Pharaoh Khafre
is guarded by the Great Sphinx which
stands near the pyramids causeway carved
out of a single block of limestone the
240 footlong statue combines the body of
a lion and the head of a man most likely
the face of the Pharaoh Khafre himself
the last of the three great pyramids is
the tomb of the Pharaoh Minkow array
many other tombs and temples are packed
into this massive necropolis which is
still a working archaeological dig here
scientists continue to make new
discoveries that add to our knowledge of
ancient Egypt many tombs are open for
the public to view with hieroglyphs and
carved reliefs depicting ancient
Egyptian life if you're willing to make
steep climbs and navigate tight corners
you can even explore the passageways of
the Great Pyramid tickets to venture
inside are limited to 300 people per day
so show up early if you want the Grand
Tour the site itself is just outside of
Cairo and is easily accessible by taxi
or bus to avoid the crowds arrive in the
early morning or early evening staying
late also has its advantages
find a good vantage point and you can
watch the Sun set over the pyramids it's
a site that's been inspiring visitors
for over 4,000 years